Speaker 1: We have an absolutely huge bit
of news and a major step forward in the criminal
investigation of Donald Trump, his associates
and his organization, and I am going to go
back to what is sometimes called the boiling
frog situation, because it really applies
here in terms of the normalization of what's
going on.
Yesterday, we learned that the Manhattan district
attorney, Cyrus Vance Jr., has convened a
grand jury to decide whether to indict former
President Donald Trump or his associates or
other elements of the Trump organization.
This means that the district attorney at least
believes that he has evidence of possible
crimes.
Otherwise, you don't convene a grand jury.
Whether the crime was committed by Trump himself
or someone close to Trump or all of the above,
we don't yet know.
And that is exactly what the grand jury will
determine.
The Washington Post reports that the panel
was convened recently and will sit three days
a week for six months.
This is not super surprising in terms of the
duration.
White collar crimes take a lot of grand jury
time.
The cases are complicated and typically grand
juries look at more than one matter.
So it probably isn't all trump all the time
for the period that they will be on the grand
jury.
Now, as you might remember, Manhattan District
Attorney Cyrus Vance has been investigating
Donald Trump's pre presidency business dealings
for more than two years now.
And part of that was slowed down because while
Donald Trump was president, he was able to
regularly obstruct Vance obtaining his tax
records.
That stopped when Trump left office.
And those records were directed to be provided
to Cyrus Vance relatively recently.
And this is an important detail.
This investigation relates to things Trump
and his company did before Trump was president
and not during.
Now, Vance's office said in court filings
that it was investigating, quote, possibly
extensive and protracted criminal conduct
at the Trump Organization.
This includes tax fraud, insurance fraud,
falsification of business records and a whole
bunch of other stuff.
Now, before looking at the details, a grand
jury looking at a former president is a huge
deal.
It's enormous.
And we have to understand that.
We're going to look at some things that former
prosecutor Renato Mariotti said.
And we're going to talk about, you know, is
Trump likely to ever go to prison?
The answer is no.
But consider the sort of, you know, the the
boiling frog in the skillet.
You slowly turn up the temperature.
It doesn't notice that it's getting burned.
Consider how far we've come where, as Sharon
GAPA said on Twitter before the presidency,
the Access Hollywood grabbed him by the You-Know-What
tape.
Oh, my goodness, this is crazy.
This is the craziest thing we've ever seen.
We have a grand jury now considering indictments
of a former president, and it didn't even
make that big of news like it made news, but
it wasn't that big.
So think about the degree to which things
have slid over the last many years.
Now, former federal prosecutor Renato Mariotti,
who has been a guest on the show, had a good
Twitter thread about the meaning of all of
this.
And just a few points that Renato makes one
quote, The mere fact that a special grand
jury was impaneled does not mean that any
particular person will be charged.
It does not necessarily mean that Trump himself
will be charged.
But it is fair to say that Vance's investigation
is far along and that charges are on the horizon
does not mean it will be against Trump number
two when it comes to Trump himself.
In cases like this, it's often about what
you can prove.
Trump knew when you're talking about this
type of fraud and white collar crime and Rinaudo
tweets, quote, Whenever I investigated tax
or fraud cases, the case came down to whether
we had sufficient proof of the defendant's
knowledge of the false statements contained
in the documents.
That state of mind is what distinguishes fraud
from a mere mistake.
A slip up is not fraud, very similar to perjury.
People say things that are not true while
under oath in court all the time.
But why don't we often see perjury charges?
Because you have to prove they didn't just
make a mistake.
It wasn't just a mis recollection that they
were really lying.
And state of mind is a big part of that.
And lastly, Renato tweets, quote, Fraud is
just when you lie to people to get their money.
So the case usually comes down to whether
the defendant knew the statements in the documents
were false.
It's easier to prove knowledge for people
involved in preparing or authorizing the documents.
Like Weissenberg, Weisenberg was one of the
top Trump organization people.
And then in terms of expectations and this
matches what I've been saying for some time,
Rinaudo tweets, quote, Don't be surprised
if people like Weissenberg are their initial
target to induce him or others to flip.
Someone like Trump or his children will only
have liability if they.
Knew of the false statements and participated
in the scheme in some way or moved it forward
somehow, so this doesn't change any of the
things we've said, Trump maybe would be charged.
No way that this leads to Trump going to prison.
But but but if Trump were a normal person,
I would probably be saying this guy's going
to prison.
They've got this guy.
And what I mean by that is think back to the
Michael Cohen indictment and and conviction.
Michael Cohen names Trump in the case in which
Michael Cohen went to prison for his crimes.
That's Trump's personal lawyer.
That would normally be a major sign that Trump
is guilty of something.
But this is a rich former president and we
have a two tiered justice system in the United
States.
In these at their core are crimes for which
you really need to prove state of mind.
So this may go on for a long time.
It will certainly trigger Trump.
I don't think Trump ends up in prison.
But let's talk about the reaction from the
former president next.